good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday i'm sorry
that it's monday i wish there was
something i could do but there's not
there's not but you know it's another
great week another great fall week the
weather is just gorgeous sublime it's as
good as a monday could be sublime yes
sublime it's as good as a monday could
be plus if we're looking on the bright
side of things even though it's starting
to get dark we did get an extra hour of
sleep this weekend which
this morning came to me in such a real
way yeah like i had and you want to know
why and how because i actually stayed up
late last night reading but then brew
woke up his internal body clock like he
doesn't know about daylight savings he
doesn't know [ __ ] mm-hmm and so i
literally woke up an hour before
you're julie do yes and i saw that i had
an hour and i was like this is so
beautiful yeah no me and ben woke up at
our alarms and we were like oh my god we
thought we like slept till 11. it i
definitely felt it it was such a
pleasure especially because
when you when if you're out on daylight
savings and it goes from being about to
be three to like
two o'clock again to or
no the opposite about to being two to
being one you get an extra hour of being
at the clubs it's the best and like i've
been there a lot of times i've also been
when you're at the club and it suddenly
is four o'clock in the morning that
[ __ ] sucks but i don't recall
recently being home on a saturday night
when we got an hour and it was just like
i watched all of waco i have to tell you
about it i mean you don't have to tell
me about it no i have to tell you about
what i'm going through since then it's
for me it was a transformative
experience yeah changed the way that i
look at the world yes it was
it was horrible
horrible i mean a good show and taylor
kitsch was amazing of course after i
watched i went and looked up what all
the people looked like the crush crushed
it david crush david correction okay
but you know this story and of course it
was before my time i knew nothing about
it now i understand my chip and joanna
gaines are so successful because i guess
before chip and joanna gaines like you
couldn't say the word wake up without
thinking about the massacre that the fbi
committed and now you think about waco
and you think about like fixer-upper so
i get why they're successful but oh my
god like first of all
the only thing i didn't like was like
it's still pretty like unclear what
actually happened because of course the
few survivors david thibodeau oh and
then wait i was having this crazy
experience watching the show because it
was like ben trying to tell you girl
like no it's separate but it was nine
o'clock i'm like ben let's watch
something but i want to watch snl roman
from succession is going to host and
only when they announced kieran culkin
as the host for snl did i realize that
roman from succession is macaulay
culkin's brother welcome to the world
it's a pleasure to be here okay wait
welcome
then when i'm watching
waco
there's this guy who looks so much like
third brother who looks so much like
kieran culkin i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on
and then i look it up and there's
another brother i think his name is
i don't know these culkins are just
running around
i didn't even know that there was more
than one mm-hmm it was the craziest like
med experience i didn't even end up
watching i sent out because we got so
into waco we stayed up till what would
have been three in the morning but it
was really like two waco we'll do that
to you oh my god so here's my question
about waco there was definitely some
loose ends because the fbi is
maintaining you know that they did
everything they had to because there was
children being abused in that
compound
but was there ever any evidence that
there were children being abused there
was evidence so i mean i'm not going to
be able to remember everything but like
david koresh like did marry the little
sister when she was like under age
that's illegal yeah well actually no
well the father gave her away
so in texas it was completely legal not
that i'm debating i'm just saying they
weren't breaking the law there was like
you know nefariousness within the cold
it wasn't all kosher no there was a time
there was religious nefariousness like
what i remember from it was like
everyone there was there on their own
accord they had cars right they could go
here they couldn't even during the
hostage situation david was like you
guys can leave yeah so
i it just really made me think i like
you didn't know the story i knew that
waco had some nefarious meaning to it
but i didn't know the story at all and
of course with everything you have to
you know evaluate who's telling the
story and there are two sides to every
story i did feel like waco this telling
of it was koresh friendly yes it was a
crush at the time it was so anti-crush
right so this was the other side of the
story everyone's heard the other side
for the last 20 years right like do you
sit and
hold like
do you have a standout with the fbi for
51 days just because you had guns like
no they had they had some losses like
ruby ridge they were there to like make
a point atf
yeah no i got i got that and i didn't
understand why they were showing us all
these old hostage situations like they
were just showing us the condition that
the fbi and the atf way like they were
trying to prove a point
they were trying to like make their
bones on waco and the uh the branch
davidians yeah and it's unclear if there
was even enough there there no they had
guns because they were like paranoid
freaks but they weren't gonna kill
anyone i just have to say like the final
scene
where the gas and the fire like i
was spoiler alert i'm trigger warning
it's literally a 10 year old show no but
i didn't know that that's i didn't when
the show is old oh everyone's already
seen it but i didn't know that that's
how it was going to end no me neither
i think i remembered hearing there was
like this you know catastrophic ending
but i didn't know what and i just wasn't
prepared for that final scene i was
frozen i was
like devastated i just couldn't go to
sleep afterwards it was the worst thing
i ever saw in my life and uh melissa
benoist was incredible incredible
so it was taylor kitsch
it was a great show it was a great show
six episodes nice quick watch you know i
don't like to watch things that are too
long
but
oh my god like if you'd like to know
where i went from there in terms of
similar content no i'm not i don't want
to like terrorize myself anymore no but
i was just like then in this like 90s
crime mood i watched richard jewell
uh oh but your jewel looks so sad it
wasn't i didn't i didn't find it to be
very good oh um but i watched manhunt
unabomber oh i've heard of it and i
thought that was really good again
you've heard of the unabomber but do you
know what he did no and i really don't
want to like sound stupid but like i've
heard of the unibomber but like i don't
know what
that is right that's how i felt too okay
and then i watched it and now i know i'm
actually gonna watch next the gwen
shamblin documentary what's that um she
was like this brian watch it he said it
was so wet that woman yes she like
started like this crazy cult what's it
called i don't know but it doesn't
uh wake up i mean after i watched waco i
did a lot of research about cults branch
civilians and then it took me on this
like path of like the definition of a
cult which is a very subjective term no
and i think also in this day and age we
just like throw that word around when
like people who are doing things by
their own accord that's like that can't
be considered a cult and that's what i
think what i liked about the show was
like they had these like benchmark
moments with that radio show host who
was just giving like a really
fair and balanced perspective on like
what the [ __ ] was going on and he had
this like expert on who was an expert in
colts and the guy was like
cult is a social construct like yes and
this is certainly not a cult all these
people have they're not being held there
by violence or blackmail like they have
all
chosen chosen this life and they love it
and they can leave right and so even
though i think it's [ __ ] weird like
live your life for yourself go live your
life on your uh compound right so you
should watch this when one see if if it
is a cult well i have no idea what it is
so i felt that way about um lula rich
they were like it's a cult i'm like
really everyone signed up and knew
exactly what they were doing and the
time of their lives like barry's there
they're enjoying all the benefits like
until things got dark like that's
actually not a cult nexium was a cult
they were branding people like we we
just throw the word cult around when we
think what people are doing is weird and
we can't relate to it but no live your
life like buy the leggings a hundred
percent yeah so it was um it was an
eye-opening experience i know i'm always
late like you tell me to watch something
and i have to wait a whole year because
i'm so [ __ ] stubborn but i did it i
just i'm looking forward to the day when
i say like i'm watching this watch it
and then you turn it on like that day i
feel like that's happened recently no
yeah like succession you were a few
years behind um but it's always a fight
it's always a struggle like yeah when
will you just trust me
and then we can be experiencing these
things together by the way i'm so glad
you brought that up because it's not
that i don't trust you i think i trust
you implicitly okay it's this thing that
i have where it's like and you bring it
up all the time like if i don't want to
do something like i will not do it like
i'm so stubborn in like my own ways
creature of habit like
if like no you know
sorry that's it like no
okay so it's enough yeah so it's gonna
be a no for me
okay well i'm glad i got to uh relive
the feelings of waco because i think
it's so important it's such a terrible
story like
and it was really hard to watch because
i find taylor kitsch to be like one of
the hottest men who ever was created on
this planet but i think he's out here
looking ugly no but it was a good he was
a great casting because you needed to
feel like the magnetism of david
crescent like how someone could fall
into this and get over 100 people to
like move into his house and david i
mean taylor kitsch like is that guy is
that guy i love him i
it's sad that when waco was on it was on
paramount when it was on and then it
made it to the streamers i don't think a
lot of people watched it live and like
it deserved to win awards yeah i agree
but if it had one at an award show i
would have been like the [ __ ] is that
literally yeah it was also like six it
was just it was honestly like the
perfect show i don't feel like they
wasted our time i agree
um
so yeah
that's what i did this weekend it was
your birthday it was my birthday i
turned 29 successfully
and it was such a nice day was extremely
low-key but the family came over we're
not like other girls not like other
girls presents cake we were chilling
laughing it was a lovely day it was good
time so i had a really nice weekend
honestly we ate so much food like the
next day i was on the phone with margo i
couldn't even pick my head up like i was
full of pizza and cake it was like i
went to a six-year-old birthday party
but i would have had it no other way no
like that night i i had so much ice
cream cake i was like coming down off of
a sugar high i couldn't move a muscle i
was like in pain yeah yeah yeah no i was
sore and everybody brought me or sent me
treats sweet treats i got like such good
stuff and i still have it in my house so
like best yeah i had some banana bread
for breakfast you know i'll have banana
pudding later post birthday treats and
sweets but now i'm like still dealing
with like i'm having too much sugar and
i had to bring it to the studio i could
take it off your hands oh that's true i
guess i could magnolia cupcakes i'll
take okay i could share because i have
the best of the best and i i want to eat
it because it's also good but like it
makes you feel like crap it really does
no but that ice cream carvel cake like
sitting in your freezer and then every
night before bed you just like take a
slice to your room there's actually
like no feeling that's even comparable
yeah i haven't even gotten into the
carvel leftovers because i have to get
into like the sitting left yeah and you
know what the carbell leftovers they
have a long shelf life so take your time
right
the you know the cupcakes they don't the
carrot cake the carrot cake i really got
did a lot of carrot cake yesterday so
that was that was good but it's just
it's overwhelming how much hundred
percent how many sweets i got and so
because you're just so sweet i'm just so
sweet so it was a really it was a great
birthday and a great weekend and we got
the extra hour i feel rested you know
i'm feeling good yeah i mean honestly i
feel like also a lot of my weekend was
consumed with like watching and reading
about what the [ __ ] went down in houston
um obviously that's a story today and i
feel like i tried to
ingest as much as i could because it was
all coming out so like slowly and then
quickly and and i was so when i first
heard about it like i was like what the
what yeah like it made no sense and i
feel like a lot of it still doesn't make
sense yeah there's a lot of different
things going on that's obviously our
first story and we'll get into it and
we'll try and you know piece together
everything that's come out so far and i
think that the biggest conversation
around it is just like where do you
place the blame on this like that's what
everyone's trying to figure out and
everybody has their different opinions i
and there's no right or wrong answer
it's just like such a tragedy that
no one can make sense of and the death
troll has risen to 11 correct
has it i believe
jesus okay yeah it's just it's literally
the worst thing i've ever heard in my
life
and it also it's just one of those
tragedies that's it so avoidable you
know yeah like so many festivals go on
year round and they're well staffed and
they're well organized and so i think
it's just a combination of it being a
really poorly run event and that does
fall on travis it does fall on live
nation however i think it was like it
was
but it's also like this larger
conversation around like the obsession
with celebrities because and you told me
this i never saw travis's documentary
but this is like his thing like he loves
for people to like go wild rage moments
documentary then the raging you know is
congruent with what you know and i
didn't know that before i watched the
documentary that that is the energy at
his shows like people in the trees
people climbing up the light posts they
encourage it jumping down from like the
balcony breaking their legs i've seen
that yeah it is a very chaotic
atmosphere and i think for
a number of different reasons that we'll
get into like it turned extremely tragic
yeah on on friday night
so
so let's get into it further ado we'll
get into the fast life stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
sorry
today's episode is brought to you by
ollie pop open up stop dropping stuff
when you snap the cards
i'm sorry what remember when you had the
cards and you would drop them no i don't
feel like that happened that much
actually i just feel like it was every
now and then um today's episode is
brought to you by olliepop a new kind of
soda that tastes just like all the ones
we grew up with but unlike other sodas
that are full of sugar corn syrup and
artificial ingredients like aspartame
lollipop is made with natural
ingredients that are actually good for
you they are the fastest growing
functional beverage brand in america and
the best part is that they have the best
flavors that are so nostalgic like a
vintage cola classic root beer orange
squeeze cherry vanilla strawberry
vanilla and their newest flavor classic
grape by the way we drank so many
lollipops at your birthday ben was
obsessed i think it was the first time
he had ever had them um it's just a
great alternative like when you're
eating like sweets and treats and you
want like a nice
cherry cola carbonated beverage but you
don't want even more sugar i have a lot
of lollipop in my fridge because it's
the perfect pregnancy because you're not
drinking soda i'm not drinking soda
because it either has too much sugar if
i drink a regular soda or a diet soda
has too many artificial ingredients and
you just can't trust it so lollipop is
much lower in sugar than conventional
sodas with only two to five grams of
sugar and it's um
they have no sugar added and their
vintage cola has just two grams of sugar
which is compared to a regular coca-cola
has 39 grams of sugar oh my that's crazy
all of their products are non-gmo vegan
paleo and keto friendly with less than
eight grams net carbs per can so we have
a special deal if you want to receive 20
off plus free shipping on your order of
lollipop we recommend trying the variety
pack it's a great way to try all the
flavors go to drink olliepop.com toast
or use the code toast at checkout to
claim the deal that's
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
toast they can also be found all of the
lollipop products and 6 000 stores
across the country including kroger
whole foods sprouts and wegmans
thank you claudium it's a pleasure
okay so
news from this weekend tragic tragic
news at least eight people are dead and
many injured after a crowd search at
travis scott's astro world festival
members of a densely packed crowd surged
toward the stage and were crushed
against each other at houston music
festival on friday night at least eight
people were killed and scores of others
were injured in the chaos witnesses and
officials said up to like 300 people
were treated for injuries the victims
who died were 14 16 two were 21 2 were
23 and one was 27 years old while one of
the victims ages remains unknown so the
there was also a ten-year-old
the ten-year-old is critically injured
um
but the victims
the you know identities are have been
coming out but there's one victim that
they can't identify they put out a
picture oh i saw it from the morgue i
saw that was a terrible picture i don't
know if they've been able to identify
him yet um but that's just awful it's so
sad you know like when you so i
i've thought before that like
sometimes the way you go to festivals
like it is so many people it is and for
in my mind this was like something like
i'm like that like gives me anxiety like
being around so many people but i think
that like for the most part people are
you know behaved and they know how to
like act
but i think there's something about
like travis's community that he really
encourages like bad behavior yeah it's
the raging it's the [ __ ] and it's the
pushing towards the stage right so if
you see videos from that day before the
concert even started it was bright out
people you know when you go to a concert
and you like you're in the parking lot
and you have to walk through all these
like barricades and then there's
security and people were just knocking
down the fences there was like 50 people
running people were getting stampeded
you know in broad days just trying to
get into the festival right so i think
that there were so many like obvious
security concerns before the concert
even started that should have been you
know addressed i know that the event was
really understaffed um and so i think
everyone's just now thinking like who do
we blame like it's yeah because this is
so upsetting there were young kids there
because you were telling me he does like
490 markets to young kids too i think
some people are like why were there kids
there but like he's an artist for kids
he does a fortnight collaboration he has
like mcdonald's like happy meal thing
like he's very much kids love him kids
love him so that's why there were kids
there right of course i i was also like
wow i didn't know kids loved travis
scott and then when you were telling me
the fortnight thing i'm like oh that
actually makes a lot of sense yeah so i
just feel like it's this kind like
and like when we when i heard this of
course this was like the most shocking
thing but then when you put all this
stuff together it's like not yeah no
especially when you even the video the
hype up video for this astro where they
use footage from old festivals and
concerts of his like they're really
hyping up like that chaotic energy and
you know the recklessness really and i
saw this morning the houston police
chief had warned travis before the
concert over like concerns over the
crowd energy um they were worried about
swelling the anxious crowd plus like
this like post pandemic yes energy the
price of the tickets like they they were
they were concerned in all 50 000 people
came no a hundred
yes i was reading something on instagram
last night that like noun sources are i
guess it's like a pr thing that they're
saying 50 000 people were there but when
the concert first was announced they
sold out in minutes all 100 000 tickets
but isn't that because it was friday and
saturday
that's how i thought of it oh that's
interesting i'm not sure but there yeah
no that's interesting they're saying
that night there were 50 000 people but
maybe there weren't there's a lot of so
there's a lot to talk about there also
wasn't a lot of security so i'm sure
people just came in yeah and also the if
you've read some of like the first hand
testimony of people who were either
witnessing like cpr being done or had it
done on themselves they were completely
overwhelmed and the medics that were
there were we're not prepared we're not
prepared
how could you like
no one expected no one expected this
right so
also there is like tmz has reported that
a security guard was stabbed with an
injection in the neck and they are
looking into claims that people were
sticked with
with drugs that might have caused them
to collapse people aren't buying that no
they're saying it's like a pr spin
because then you can place blame on the
person who was doing that right and like
i mean i don't know it all sounds
believable to me like this was a very
low security event you know when we've
been to many festivals like they
literally check between your butt cheeks
like they don't take this [ __ ] lightly
because
of so many terrible things that have
happened in the past and you know what
it's really annoying but i'm always
grateful for it yeah but you can't even
bring in like a cigarette like they're
insane yeah so
the what i've heard from people on the
ground was like it was a mess like there
was no security so the idea that
somebody could have brought in a
backpack full of needles and like
started stabbing people with whatever
that the security guard had to be
resuscitated with narcan like that's not
unbelievable to me no and it would
explain why so many people were
unconscious but if you see footage of
people who are like filming in the
middle of the match like begging for
help
no space their lungs can't literally
process one breath then no actually that
doesn't make any sense like all these
people and if you think about how many
people were there and the fact that
300 people out of 50 like it's
it's not normal no
so if you've read the testimonies like
once travis came up to the stage there
had been festival going on all day once
travis came on everybody towards the
stage and the people towards the front
like lost their footing couldn't breathe
people on top of them and then people
start falling to the ground and that's
where it's like over because people just
start
they don't see you it's pitch black and
also the person behind you is getting
pushed so it's not it's it's coming from
so far back now
there's videos of travis seeing what's
going on in the crowd seeing people
passed out and continuing to sing and a
lot of people are saying that he should
have stopped the show and of course in
hindsight he should have stopped the
show right and also now a lot of videos
are populating like because when you
think like stop the show what do you
mean it's a performance
there now people are just showing videos
of adele billy eilish niall horan like
literally every famous person videos of
them stopping shows and just being like
everyone take three steps back get this
girl water harry styles did it like it's
not for me it sounds like i've never
been to a show where someone stopped the
show but you know what it happens a lot
because it is the responsibility of a
performer to make sure everyone around
them is okay and in those situations the
performer is the only person who has
power who has the power so who people
can hear and people who are listening to
like when he says jump they're jumping
he says quake the ground
through and so i'm sure a lot of people
saw the video of that girl climbing up
to the camera guy saying stop the show
stop
there's people that are dying and he's i
mean he didn't stop the show he could
have you know walkie-talkie didn't try
to help but
the only person who could have actually
made the show or made a difference is
travis and i think that so there's all
these videos and so and the videos that
he sees like people being lifted out of
the crowds but again like that is
commonplace
for a travis scott show people go
unconscious right and i don't think we
thought people were dying right weirdly
that is something that is considered
normal at a festival for someone
especially at a travis show a travis
scott festival yes that someone is
unconscious they get crowd surfed out
and they're gonna get the medical
attention that they need so he's seeing
that he's not stopping the show because
i think he thinks that that's
normal
i don't and what they've said is he had
no idea people were dying in there i
mean okay so like this is like something
we've been talking about recently like
when you see a video and it's like he's
like like
seeing someone being passed out carried
out and continues to go on with the show
like oh man he knew someone died and he
kept going on i have to imagine and this
is just me being an eternal optimist i
have to imagine that if travis scott
knew like people were actually dropping
dead
he would have stopped the show like
that's just what yeah so i think that
what he saw from his vantage point and
this is just me again and people are
running to blame him and i do blame him
like a hundred percent
but i don't necessarily think it's fair
to assume he knew what exactly what was
going on i don't think that he did
either but he has a responsibility to be
more responsible to look out for stuff
like that when you're putting people in
such a compact chaotic environment you
need to be worried about the worst case
scenario and if like your brand is going
to be this like crazy mosh swinging from
trees you have to have
not only the average like the the base
amount of security protocols you need to
go above and beyond and not only did
they not even have the arrow they didn't
go above and beyond they didn't even
have the average like they had no staff
no security
so few medics so if you're gonna
encourage that [ __ ] psychotic
behavior you also have to compensate
with
making sure people are at the end of the
day safe and they were not
they were not and just
if you're looking at the crowd and they
were screaming but again it's hard to
hear them saying stop the show
over what he hears he has things in his
ear but like you need to be watching for
for these things if this is the
environment that you're fostering yeah
and honestly like
it is really chilling to see like the
video of literally this like
one medic trying to give multiple people
cpr there's sirens in the middle of the
crowd and travis is like looking like
yeah and so people are upset also
because kylie was there with stormy and
kendall and they were filming the night
and in one of kylie's videos you see an
ambulance driving through the crowd and
people are like she's there enjoying her
life like she sees an ambulance and why
still nothing was done
i mean i've never seen an ambulance at a
music festival i haven't been to that
many and i never get into the thick of
things really um but i also think that
that is something that doesn't that
doesn't mean like that the absolute
worst thing has happened no of course
because again at concerts and especially
at travis scott concerts people are so
excited they pass out i agree i think a
lot of people are looking again for
someone to blame and the kardashians are
such an easy
group to blame i do think
the only kind of problem i have with
with kylie and the kardashians in all of
this it's just kind of like a
like a lack of response like all we got
was like an instagram story
statement like i don't know i just feel
like more could be done roddy rich has
announced that like he every dollar he's
made net is going to the families of
the people who lost their lives and i
just think like travis and kyle have
just like been putting out like
like nothing like instagram like garbage
yeah and it's disappointing because
in no way is kindly responsible but like
people look to you and you were there
like and you know you had security and
you but you got you and your daughter
out safely but like most people don't
nobody else has that luxury so i just
think like the lack of
like a real
empathetic response is really
disappointing yeah they they definitely
could be doing more
i'm now also people are starting to sue
so live nation and travis and drake was
there too and injured fans are suing and
that's by the way that's kind of what
brought this whole thing to head it's
like it was already crazy people were
dropping and then he brought drake out
yeah and so the surge just went even
further and honestly i don't know how
travis scott like goes on from here i
don't know how he performs live ever
again i don't know either but i also
think this should be like a lesson
in just festivals in general yeah
because i've always felt that like this
large group of people it just doesn't
make any sense it should really be like
a grid like there should be like little
like it just doesn't make sense i it
needs to be changed yeah i agree and so
i
i don't think there's just one thing
that could have changed it or is the
reason for it but i think it it
highlights a bigger issue and just like
this culture of chaos
like it just needs to be reevaluated
because this this can't happen and now
like when you see all the elements put
together it's like a disaster waiting to
happen right you're like how did we not
see this coming but then when we when i
first heard about it i'm like holy [ __ ]
you're like how does this happen like
eight people died at a concert i'm like
okay well did someone come with a gun
like it just doesn't make any sense that
eight people just dropped dead yeah so
it's it's literally like the worst thing
i've ever heard like when you when you
see the videos it's all over my tick
tock it is so sad and people just
telling their stories like literally
this girl was like i fell and some
random person picked me up and literally
saved my life yeah like it's just and
that's what it was there was no staff no
one could get through she was literally
just everyday concert goers like that
girl who tried to she's a [ __ ] hero
[ __ ] here on the guy on the ladder
who was up there with her right and he's
like yelling at the people who are
yelling at him like get down like i
think they called him a [ __ ] because he
was like trying to stop the show right
so it was just like
it was like the
like the weirdly like the best of
humanity like people just helping people
they don't know the worst so people
didn't know what they were doing when
they're running forward like i don't
think anyone thought like oh let me mosh
in this crowd it might kill someone like
that's just not
something most people think yeah
like i don't think any nobody was ever
trying like smushed so hard that we're
going to collapse people's lungs but
we're like yeah let's go hard like i
don't think that and eventually no
matter how hard you mosh there's a
hundred thousand people behind you
pushing up it's out of your control yeah
so it's just it's a horrible [ __ ]
story yeah and it's so should not have
happened
and so people are angry and people are
looking for someone to blame and travis
is the most obvious choice he really is
yeah and they're also coming for kylie
they're coming for kylie and i just i
don't know what
what that does me neither cause i'm sure
she saw it getting out of hand and she
left early with her eight security
guards she's pregnant and she's pregnant
she had her baby
but
it's like if she had sensed like [ __ ]
was going wrong like how
how could she not tell travis you know
but she wasn't near him well she went
backstage she could have told someone
yeah i don't know but i don't know what
she saw again that's like it's hard to
you know
and it's crazy
this is getting out of hand this is
travis's thing let me get stormy out of
here yeah it's crazy the show went on
for like 40 more minutes once it started
he like finished the show because he
didn't know
um
but he is saying now that he cut the
show short
oh and like it was supposed to be like
175 minutes and it was 100 or whatever i
don't know maybe not those exact numbers
but he said on his instagram stories
that he cut the show short i think
that's his pr team saying and maybe it
was cut like five minutes short or 20
minutes short yeah but not as short as
it should have been cut yeah definitely
i just i mean i'm sure for them it's
like you know he didn't know it at the
time what was happening
but he's the only one who could have
done it done anything and like that is
something he has to live with yeah it's
it's uh and he posted like those
instagram stories being like extremely
distressed
i i can't imagine no oh my god it's
it's horrible
and like there's still so many people
are injured like critically right so and
you said that you saw that the death i
did but you didn't see that so i don't
want to misspeak i didn't see that let
me just look it up okay
yeah
um
we could come back to it yeah
oh it still says eight okay i saw eleven
on tick tock i'm sorry i didn't mean to
misspeak
no this was three hours ago from the new
york times so
um yeah just
a horrendous horrendous thing that
happened this weekend that's so sad
and honestly just like so unfair yeah
you go to a concert to enjoy your life
who how do you die at a concert you know
like when you go to concert it's like
the height of like
happiness
yeah and you of course whenever you
leave your house or you're on public you
think hey what's the worst thing that
could happen to me and i guess at a
concert the worst thing is like maybe
someone slips something in my drink like
that's what is on my mind like never
does it ever occur to me that i could
die at this concert yeah
yeah
it's really really also crazy travis
refunded all the tickets
obviously obviously and um
i just hope that the families of i mean
are being properly like compensated
taken care of and are just like
i can't even imagine like sending your
kid to a concert and he
dies a 14 year old horrible
ninth grade oh stop that's so sad
beyond
anyways
we'll keep you posted just think of
everyone yeah
are you ready for our next story yes
major pivot please in the largest way
another big event this weekend took
place and it was new york city marathon
oh yeah and the stars came out to run
yes a lot of bachelor people the
bachelor took over the marathon we had
tyler c and matt james running together
tasha and zach ran together
peter webber ran peter weber ran yeah he
didn't make the headlines well because
somebody did um
somebody on tick tock did like a list of
all the bachelor nation people who ran
okay and in order of like slowest to
fastest and peter was the slowest person
who ran and taisha and zach were they
were faster than
tyler c and matt but i did see a lot of
videos on tick tock of tyler c and matt
like stopping saying hi to people all
along the way because people were like
dying so um maybe that's why and okay so
i don't know why yesterday i was like
kind of into the marathon of course i
love seeing people achieve their goals
and especially when people are running
for a cause that is so important to them
and i didn't know this until recently
but like to get into the new york city
marathon like it's like getting into
college no it's hard you have to be
accepted you have to like raise all this
money in order to do it you would think
they got to pay people to do the
marriage literally but like you
literally have to pay no and like you
can't even my doorman who runs marathon
every year he was supposed to run in
2020 and i guess like obviously he was
canceled so then this is the most recent
one and there were so many more people
he had to be shoved till next year wow
he couldn't even run this here right so
like it's a very prestigious thing to be
even able to
enter and to get on you know get on
these streets so tyler c was running for
his mom the angelia see cameron
foundation which is so sweet so nice and
so i just
was thinking about how it must feel to
like finish that physical feat
and then also the emotion of like what
you're doing it for your mom or your
cause or whatever no totally it just
like was really
getting me in my field yeah and i was i
had a crazy thought which was like no
jackie please seriously stop don't even
say what you're about to say
i had a crazy thought which was like
i would like to know how that feels one
day are you going to run the marathon
seriously not please don't talk to me
like honestly not anytime soon okay i'm
in no state okay in my life to run the
marathon
but it's on your list of things to do it
was the first time i was like
you could understand why people
understand yes exactly okay
yeah remember when olivia ran the half
marathon yeah you know she really did
that like she really did that i'd look
disassociated from that but like she
lowkey ran 13 miles like that's crazy
really crazy i mean just the whole
marathon concept and like so i was
watching tasha's stories and it was so
cute because like people spotted her and
like tagged her and just you she's
literally all over the city she's uptown
she's downtown
like it's just so crazy yeah i don't
know why the marathon just hit different
this year because you're like a hella
emotional with your pregnancy me yeah
but it is this like gorgeous thing like
it's a gorgeous thing it really is yeah
i'll never know what that's like but i'm
really happy for other people
how long does it take to walk the
marathon well eventually if you're going
so slow they cut you off like the thing
can't go on all day right like traffic
is being right
so i've heard people who have like five
hour
times like the really good people do it
in like three
yeah i think like uh
zach and tasha were like five hours yeah
which is amazing i don't know at what
point do they literally say go home but
like if you're all the way in the back
and it's clear you're not so i don't
know if you can really walk the whole
thing because what is like a walking a
mile like 15 minutes
yeah so it's 26 times 15.
hit us with the calculator
390 divided by minutes 60.
six and a half that actually doesn't
sound so bad a 15-minute walking mile
though i think is like quick oh it's for
every mile yeah i mean yeah for every
mile right right yeah just interesting
stuff congratulations to everyone who
ran if we have any toaster marriages
congratulations seriously be so proud of
yourself totally like are you what do
your legs feel like today like oh my god
they must feel like jello yeah
crazy
crazy marathon tanks also it was an
absolutely beautiful day it was a
perfect day for my marathon really
really was
okay ready for our next story sure
kanye west is apparently dating model
venetria amid kim kardashian and pete
davidson rumors i'm sorry connie is so
messy like you literally just went on a
radio show and we're like complaining
that you and your wife are getting
divorced like you want to be a family
but you also have a girlfriend who was
at sunday service yesterday
so was kim though
right did you see that no i didn't i saw
came in northwest sunday service in l.a
yesterday so that just like warms my
kimmy's heart you know but i also want
them to have people on the side so this
all this situation is working for me
sure sources tell page six that the
rapper who said in an interview tape
last month that he still wants to be
with estranged wife kim oh he said that
in the internet
last month oh taped but i guess it aired
last week yes but it was after snl
clearly so it was like probably two
right after yeah
um he has been hooking up with venetria
for a while now where page six is also
told that venetria was in miami with
kanye when he recorded the now viral
interview and was seen at his sunday
service last weekend
their situation ship appears to be
taking a more serious turn they attended
their first public event together this
weekend his donda academy's debut
basketball game in minneapolis oh wow
they were through the court side oh wow
so this isn't just like whispers it's
not just like irena shake no but there
was pictures of them was there yeah like
on a plane on the like the private plane
yeah i mean this is cute whatever like i
just
i just don't really know what's going on
like i'm feeling very in this like
transitional phase where it's like
they're together they're not together he
wants to be together she has a boyfriend
but like is it real like i'm just i'm
feeling very confused and like very on
edge you know what i'm feeling like i'm
feeling like every day is different for
all these people like they're in a state
of transition i feel like one day they
wake up and they're good and the next
day they see something about the other
and it's like
you know beef um i feel like they're as
confused right now as we are honestly i
mean it definitely feels that way yeah
but i'm glad that like if kim is with
pete which i want her to see this thing
through yeah then kanye should be with
venetria yeah
well
you don't have a wedding this weekend
that kim is going to be at yeah and
we look forward to all the tea that
you'll bring you want to know what's
like so annoying about my life like not
to make everything about me but like i
was invited to three celebrity weddings
they're all on the same weekend
for dana yeah she's a podcast host i was
literally invited to three celebrity
weddings they're all in the same weekend
and i can only go to one
is this not right that's not right like
the universe knows how much i crave like
celebrities yeah and to put it all on
one weekend it's just maybe like this
just means you've reached a new tier of
celebrity yourself if like you're
invited to four no i really like that
you're four times the celebrity that you
once were you're really putting a nice
spin on it i really like that
but i feel like i'm going to the best
one you know
i i i have no qualms about the one that
you know like simon's one of my best
friends like i have to go and if i like
was thirsty and like left he would be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing simon's
wedding is gonna be sickening sickening
and you know i will report back like on
what i say yeah just keep your eyes open
ears open legs open
always okay anyways i'm happy for kanye
just you know keeping up with the
kardashians it's not as easy as it used
to be it's not as easy as it used to be
but it's exciting excitement excites me
and these games drops tomorrow and i'm
feeling overwhelmed oh yes and i've
gotten a lot of dms that it's going to
be in stores it's like inside
my heart it's in like boutiques and
stuff so i don't know if this is going
to be like selling out so fast or it's
just a mainstay it's expensive so like
things like that expensive don't sell
out in five minutes but like sometimes
the bots hop on they buy it all and then
they market it it's like yeezy yeah you
know stockx like yeah yeah yeah
so that's gonna be me i'm gonna have to
wake up early for this what time is it
at 9am eastern
right it's my calendar that is so cool
in pacific
that doesn't make any sense i feel like
it's 12 a.m it's when the store is open
probably oh maybe i should just go to
store i don't know i didn't even plan my
buy like i'm just feeling really
stressed well we'll get to it don't
worry okay i need to i need a [ __ ]
line sheet can someone send one to me oh
you have like all the stuff yeah i've
been looking for it and yeah that's a
good call i only just see like promo
pics yeah
that's a good question i don't know
someone needs to be asking the tough
questions here i agree are you ready for
our next story only the next story is
brought to you by id tech let's face it
many kids aren't thrilled by math until
we connect it to things that they
already care about and enjoy and that's
the magic of id tech's instructors they
make abstract concepts relatable and
help students latch onto math and other
stem subjects as actual interests not
only that but they'll help your kids
fill learning gaps explore topics not
covered in school advance quickly and
have fun doing it i wish there was
something like this around when i was a
kid because right now id tech is
offering a great deal you can get
started with a one-on-one tutoring
session
for just forty nine dollars or you can
save a hundred and fifty dollars on
weekly small group semesters ig tech is
where kids and teens learn from the best
their live instructors make learning fun
with engaging courses in coding design
game development math and more they now
offer a variety of math homework help
options so you and other kids can
you and your kids can stress less and
celebrate more when they ace those
assignments go to idtech.com
toast right now and use the code toast
to save 150 on weekly small group
semesters for a limited time you can
also start with a one-on-one tutoring
lesson for just 49. that's code toast at
i d
tech dot com slash toast to save 150
your child can start learning online
from a live instructor right now at
idtech.com
toast thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our next story a little more romance
news ben affleck and jennifer lopez
kissed during airport drop
drop-off they say it's difficult for
them to be apart
for ben and jen distance makes the heart
grow fonder after spending the weekend
together in la ben brought j.lo to the
airport for a flight to vancouver on
sunday while on the tarmac the pair
shared a passionate kiss i saw it was
before they parted ways yeah no they're
definitely like
not in business anymore yeah i mean
honestly like
i've just become so skeptical of
everything these days like they
definitely give me fraudulent vibes for
sure i know that they were and maybe i
don't really subscribe to everything
that they do so to me it seems like
they've been quiet for a while no
they're like always like doing like
staged walks through central park like
they're like they're fraudulent a little
bit okay but it's been a while now yes
it has so at what point does the fraud
turn for real i just don't know how like
two people can constantly be getting
caught doing pda like you know what i
mean yeah no they're definitely calling
the but that also doesn't mean if
they're calling paparazzi doesn't mean
their relationship isn't real it just
means they want to you know reap all the
benefits from their relationship and i
respect that i do yeah and i'm sure they
also have like private moments you know
we only see them every once in a while
it feels like a lot to us but there's 24
hours in a day yeah no i'm i'm happy for
them honestly i'm just happy whatever
this relationship bears fruit whatever
the phrases i'm just glad that like she
came out on top of the a-rod thing
that's literally all that matters yeah
no and i'm happy for him he seems really
i'm just i'm here for all of it yeah he
always
feels like this book is closed like i
feel like i can close the book like put
it on the shelf like i will not be
pulling it out anytime soon to like talk
about a breakup right now they're like
together for the foreseeable future
right yeah i mean that would be great
because i just don't think you go back
to an ex like that and in such like a
public way someone who you're so serious
with it's not gonna be like okay this
time it's we're sticking together that
like is so crazy like how they were
literally engaged right yeah
so they know each other you know it
isn't like
but they're re-knowing each other in a
more mature beautiful way yeah they're
getting to know each other again it's
literally a nancy meyer's novel like
it's literally a movie sorry not at all
it's literally like one of those movies
that takes place in like
connecticut yeah
yeah the big star the other big star
home from the big city
it's literally a hallmark of me it's
beautiful yeah it's nice no i'm i'm not
a hater i'm really not but they're just
like kind of thirsty but you know what
respect serious so much respect are you
ready for our fifth and final story
oh yeah
it's the final story
nancy
myers
ben and jayla
nice crushed it crushed it
for the minus story's little content
news faith hill and tim mcgraw our star
in the trailer for the highly
anticipated yellowstone prequel oh 1883.
oh wait what
new show is coming out called 1883 it is
the prequel to the show yellowstone and
it is starring faith hill who plays
matriarch margaret dutton do you watch
yellowstone i watched like the first two
episodes and i literally thought it was
too bad you're so wrong we'll see you in
a year no i know going on and on
you have to talk about this new show you
just found called the yellow stone
literally so yeah we'll talk to you
later
faith hill plays matriarch margaret
dutton and tim mcgraw plays the dutton
family patriarch it's the same family
that's in yellowstone but it's about 150
years prior oh wow so also sam elliott
is in the show and billy bob thornton no
wait the fact that like they're cast
like husband and wife and their husband
and wife is the cutest [ __ ] thing
look at this promo pic it's like
legit 1883 tim mcgraw is a good actor
like i know nobody gives some credit for
his work and country strong but he was
amazing blindside the blind said he's a
really good actor i think a lot of
people forget that because he's such
like a superstar singer
um i have not seen faith hill act in
anything but there's nothing she can't
do
um so i feel like this is gonna be
really good yeah it premieres december
19th on power mount plus and i mean it's
gonna be such a success yellowstone came
back last night i didn't watch i
i'm conflicted i kind of want to save i
want to batch them but i don't want
anything to be spoiled for me because
the last season ended on such a
cliffhanger and so far no one has
spoiled anything you better [ __ ] keep
it that way
um
but it's just i don't know so
so much going on yeah
so but i'm glad yellowstone is back
because it really is the best show yeah
and you know what i just realized i'll
definitely be watching 1883. chris lane
and lauren lane they named their child
gutten after yeah but inspired by in the
family that's crazy
that is so cute it's actually a really
cute name yeah um so yeah i don't watch
and i'm sure i will but like honestly i
just didn't like it
it was like so boring like it's a slow
burn but then there's the payoff i mean
not everything is going to be like so
the shows where like something dramatic
happens all the time not realistic
you've got to invest dynasty that's so
funny that you bring that up because
that's what i've been binge watching the
new season i can't watch it anymore all
week i've been watching dynasty and
weekend and you know what it's just it's
so ridiculous but it really is just the
perfect show for where i'm at right now
because it's like a lit it's like fun
funny mindless also you know there's a
lot going on
i am really enjoying it i really am it's
it's
it has it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
it has some really great moments though
and just like the love fashion the house
fashion in the house love between fallon
and liam is just so beautiful and strong
like
obsessed obsessed
and the cat i mean actually something
happened on one of the episodes that
actually shocked me and you could say it
i'm not gonna watch
no it's like such a big spoiler okay i'm
gonna say it you guys i'm counting down
from 10 because this is a huge [ __ ]
spoiler dynasty spoiler 10
nine
eight
seven get your remote six five press
pause four
three
two
one
anders dies
what
yeah no out of like nowhere
why he got into a car accident yeah you
know what knowing that show he'll be
back right of course with like a new
face right but it was just like what
caleb nicholl doesn't want to be on the
show anymore no literally it was such a
mainstay and he was like the best
character i'm shook you know usually
someone like goes into a comb like it's
one of those shows where like every soap
opera yeah everything like happens but
no one's actually getting killed off
really unless they decide they don't
want to be on the show anymore so i was
really surprised when that happened
that's insane yeah no i was like what
that's crazy yeah
and apparently the season gets crazier
and i'm not even i'm not done yet so
that's what i've been enjoying and it's
been quite enjoyable spoiler alert is
over thank you for sharing that's crazy
come back up yeah you can come back
um well speaking of tv there was a lot
of tv on last night we obviously are
going to recap the first part of the
reunion from real housewives of potomac
and last night we finally got a glimpse
into jen shaw's arrest on the real
houses of salt lake city you guys those
last 15 minutes of salt lake city like
i've never experienced something like
that i made ben watching i'm like ben
watch this when they're like sitting in
the car talking about jen and you see in
the corners the the first police when
they zoomed in jack i swear my knees
buckled like the [ __ ] swat team
dropped in a minivan on these housewives
and it's like homeland security nypd
yeah like it's the big guns and they
were so unaware like blissful they
really believed jen
and i'm so i have to say jen kept her
cool
unbelievably well how did she get a car
to come pick her up so fast it was her
aunt he was still there that was the
truck she was dropped off in
he was still there i believe or he might
have left two minutes prior and came
back but i never saw him leave to begin
with whitney should have left her my gun
but like when he didn't think anything
nefarious no of course like you got a
private call you want to turn your mind
up that's just like what girlies do for
each other okay so let's do potomac
first um okay potomac reunion part one
was pretty boring i'm not gonna lie it
was a lot of personal stuff like
gizelle's personal life um
mia how she met the thing is like
everyone's just so nasty to me and it
bothers me so much like
when candace had the absolute goal to
call her a liar when like mia's been so
open about every single thing in her
life that she was a stripper she met her
husband at the strip club like there's
so much
honor in that and these women are just
like so nasty like
they're so so nasty especially tamiya
and she i agree she's not a liar
whatsoever she's such an open book and i
also like like and we said this too like
mia's all over the place she flip-flops
one day she says this in exit she says
that and she's like i say how i feel and
i feel different things at different
times i actually understood that no but
it's also a lesson in like why you
shouldn't just say the first thing that
comes to mind
but she's keeping it real yeah i think
the most like important part of last
night's episode um and that andy really
did finally kind of like
his job is really not to take sides but
just to ask questions but every now and
then he does like have to make a point
and i think the point that he made with
candace which did not get through to
candace but gisele was 100 right on and
everyone was just kind of wanting her to
see except for wendy like wendy's blind
spot is candace because she like refuses
to say anything bad about me he is so
annoying she's sorry so and i'm starting
to like sympathize with robin because a
hundred percent robin speaks like wendy
comes in and it's like can i say what
like stop no seriously she's so annoying
it's she's so annoying she doesn't let
anyone else speak she's constantly like
talking over everyone in such an
annoying way she has seen like so many
episodes of housewives and she's written
down like how to get attention and she's
doing it all and it's working for her
she's sitting next to andy she has this
big poster board like she's just trying
to have a moment zen when like she's
trying to have all of these things no
but yes she does that like tick tock the
clock yeah literally literally
she does those things like trying to be
like during the medley but then she also
like just doesn't let people speak even
when it's they're not even it's not
heightened like it's just right robin
how are you doing i'm good yes i'm good
yeah yeah she's like escalating
everything that is like even like just
calm conversations
i just i never thought i would be
feeling sympathetic towards right now
totally this i've had this like weird
genesis because you know what like
giselle is the worst but she's really
the only one who was like going at
candace like
maybe not intentionally but justice for
monique yes no but it's like giselle
isn't you know unreliable
champion yes because it's like you liked
it when it was she was going after your
enemy so it's just like you're you're
not consistent no not at all but andy do
you have to be principled against this
behavior and you know what the crying
from candace like absolutely has to stop
because once she started crying in her
record label meeting i knew that her her
tears mean absolutely nothing and she
could just do it on cue and so the
crying over everything is just so
[ __ ] annoying and i just have no
sympathy for it
when she was crying when she said that
her in-laws watch the show and then
she's like go over there yeah and that
was like extremely real it was like
awkward and
i believed her when she said like
i think she's in a really tough spot
with her husband and her mom right now
like and i
i don't know where she's gonna go from
here i think she's like so in it yeah
that did feel real for sure but it's
just like knowing that she can cry so on
cue about like asinine things and
i just don't i don't have no sympathy
for it anymore like yeah even last year
when she was crying so much i'm like why
is she crying so much over this like
canvassing like it wasn't i mean this
monique thing like wasn't that big of a
deal and it's like months later and
you're still crying and now i know it's
because she can cry whenever she wants
yeah so i have no sympathy and andy was
finally just like do you think that
you're getting anywhere with the way you
respond to people not only like
physically um
provoking them but also going so below
the belt big head wide ass big feet like
everything is just like such your mom
like everything is so below the belt
like you're getting nowhere and she's so
standing her ground thinking she's right
it's insane how you can be so wrong in
every little thing that comes out of
your mouth and be so like cavalier in
your righteousness it's insane it's
insane i just want to give a shout out
to really all of the women um because
they looked amazing unbelievable and i
was trying to think of my best dressed
and i there are so many yeah and i could
only think of the ones that i didn't
like because i i i loved candace's look
yeah me too i liked robin's silver like
she brought silver element i loved that
off the shoulder robin looked great
ashley looked amazing loved her hair her
dress her glam she really did look like
a barbie giselle
looked
fine good like she didn't look bad so
she looked good yeah like it was a dress
like a it was like mother of the bride
she like understood the assignment it
was fine it was fine yeah i didn't like
wendy's dress it was just a lot um
karen's like i love karen karen looked
great i'm sorry she looked regal and
ethereal and beautiful and i just love
her mia looked amazing amazing looked
amazing yeah all together amazingness i
don't know who's best dressed like
because they all really wore like the
same thing but like different variations
i don't know why i just like loved
candace's look she got a lot of fun for
her um
hair oh i like the hair i loved it and
then i loved the dress i thought she
looked great very sophisticated yes
yeah but everyone looked great like it
was it was a pleasure it's a pleasure
um so yeah it was like a part one
ringing like nothing crazy happened
everyone well really wendy's just like
escalating every conversation it's like
we're just talking about like you know
giselle's kid getting her license like
it's not she was just like
especially for giselle like she was just
coming after everyone but especially
gizelle but she's just silent on the
candace stuff and it's so annoying
because like yeah you know i can use
actually your annoying energy on candace
yep but she doesn't do it nope
um also when they showed the nicki minaj
video like knowing that she's coming out
the video part was so awkward okay what
was that blurry ass like tiny video i
don't know i think they really expected
that she would be there because she said
that she would be there so they wanted
to like throw them off i wonder if they
were thrown off yeah i mean andy was
being like a little too like she's
really sad she couldn't come he said it
like five times but you know what i
wondered because it's like so many
people are fans so many celebrities are
fans of housewives beyonce
and so i guess it has to be like you
have to be a big enough celebrity and
you have to be wanting to come like
because we know like rihanna watches
yeah
like would she ever want to go to a
vanderpump rules reunion well she never
publicly asked like nikki did right so i
think he's like really emotionally
invested in like the story lines and
she's like she wants justice no and i'm
so excited for this just because she's
going i'm literally so excited and i
just what episode does she come three
probably three yeah
that the name only comes out of her
mouth because they do say last season
yeah season they say binder but they
don't say monique the best part of the
entire episode was and it was just the
perfect point is gisele said after you
like got so in
mia's face through the salad said
horrible things to her and she clocked
you i would have been like
you know like that's what everyone's
thinking that's what was the whole point
with the monique stuff it's like you
can't just berate someone and berate
someone rates them and be mad when they
fight back no and what's so crazy this
is where candace's logic is just
empty where she's like where they're
like you threw the salad at mia first
and she's like i threw one piece of
lettuce it doesn't matter
what you started it like you gave the
idea yeah like what because it was one
lettuce yeah what do you like so how
many lettuces until it's it's too much
less right right like what is the
equation
two lettuce is that okay or is that
where we draw the line two lettuce
totally totally like
and when andy said like you're the
common denominator that's just like
needed to be said and it just it went
completely above her head like she just
doesn't she refuses to operate in a
space where she could potentially be the
problem
it's
it's a painful to watch
it's giving jorinda on her final season
it's painful to watch delusional
um so yes i'm very much looking forward
to what comes next especially the nicki
minaj of it all like that is just so
crazy it's historic
yeah so anyways i just like wonder now
is this gonna be something that might
happen in a different city you know and
how big of a like so many like
so many stars watch bravo they gonna
watch it up inside they comment
like
how big
well i think the nicki minaj thing is
different for a multitude of reasons one
she's when you think of the people who
love bravo you think like christy teigen
nicki minaj is more famous than all of
them yeah and also nicki minaj is like a
fixture in the black community the show
is like all about like
lifting up black women like i think that
it was like the perfect match no no i'm
so here for it i just wonder if it's
going to open the door for more
celeb cameos no i don't think so i think
we're witnessing this a lifetime one and
done i think we're witnessing a once in
a lifetime moment that works for me me
too i don't want like more people coming
in like because you know people have the
worst tickets i know and then what if
it's someone that we hate like like it's
exciting because it's nikki right and
we're excited yeah and excitement
excites us yeah but what if it's someone
who sucks that i don't want to see and i
don't care about their opinion and
they're wrong on everything right and
what if someone came in like team
candace and i feel that way like when a
lot of celebrities go on watch rapping's
live and they like love bravo and andy
asks them their opinion like they have
the worst takes like ever did you watch
watch what happens live last night no
okay i had to because i just needed more
salt lake city ben was like if you don't
turn this tv off i'm gonna kill you like
i was literally being held at like yeah
okay so chloe feynman was on with lisa
barlow yes
and there were some really good moments
and she did all these impressions that
were so [ __ ] she's so good like andy
was usually like cuts the game short
because he suck ass but
he like played the game until there was
no more questions or cards left like
because she was so good and lisa had to
like guess which she had to say a quote
in an accent of someone and lisa had to
guess who said what she was doing who no
no not who she was doing because they
told her who to do but she had to guess
who said the quote from salt lake city
got it and lisa got every single one so
together they were just like a dynamic
duo it was a real it was really fun
but when asked all these different
questions about
beverly hills salt lake city like
what i didn't her takes like stunk jen i
mean
oh chloe it was infuriating like
she barely answered each question and
when she did like she didn't say
anything she probably doesn't really
watch that no she does okay i think andy
double checks
yeah he does okay no she it was clear
that she was [ __ ] it was just like she
was giving us nothing right so that's
why like in the way of like hot takes
we'll see if what happens with nikki
cause like if she has bad takes then
like we'll never do this again like i
will never watch but i have a feeling
nikki like is gonna come out swinging
like yeah and she's gonna have some
really good takes i'm so excited me too
um now we need to dive into salt lake
city which was like the television event
of the year um which is brought to you
by bite toothpaste did you know that
over a billion plastic toothpaste tubes
are thrown out every year ending up in
landfills and oceans that's 50 empire
state buildings worth of plastic
and that's why bite was invented
reinventing personal care by making
products that are good for you and the
planet their hero product is the dry
toothpaste tablets that come in a
reusable glass jar the refills come in
home compostable
compostable pouches so you just pop one
in your mouth bite down and brush it's
like the most
effective way to brush your teeth and
also the best of the planet it foams up
just like a regular toothpaste but
there's no plastic tube or messy paste
it's so cool it's so cool and also like
the
toothpaste tube is just like kind of
chaotic it's just kind of over like it's
disgusting it's gross like your hair
gets in it like it's gross like so this
is more hygienic it's more pretty on
your counter but it's also
a good cause because it's much better
for the environment yeah they are also
made with clean ingredients no harsh
chemicals sulfates or artificial dyes or
flavors the sustainability and clean
ingredients are at the center of
everything that they do they are
certified carbon neutral cruelty free
vegan and palm oil free also the
products are just great like it's a
great toothpaste minty fresh gets the
job done just as good if not better than
regular toothpaste and you also don't
have to deal with like the disgusting
nature
of your
plastic tubes bite is offering our
listeners 20 off your first subscription
order go to trybite.com
toast or use code toast at checkout to
claim this deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e dot com slash toast check
it out um i don't think you'll regret it
i don't
let's talk about salt lake city okay
before we get to like obviously the meat
and potatoes it was a really long
episode like that was like full of
nothing they were just like really
dragging us out the only thing that was
weird was like this whole america like
mary woke up and chose violence at the
have been a merry apologist and
she's always been quirky and she's
always been married and i've given her
the space to be both of those things and
like she doesn't have to be like other
girls she doesn't have to be like other
households
she's different yeah and i appreciate
that about her and i've appreciated it
but the way she behaved last week it
started with the google yeah and by the
way lisa barlow said something i'm
watching what happens live that made
like me even more certain so lisa was
like
i drink so much diet coke that when i
heard that carbonation could like you
know bring on early menopause i'm like i
need to google this right like it was it
was more imperative not just her
fact-checking marriage no i didn't and i
never felt like she was fact-checking
mary period right when someone tells you
something that actually could have like
direct implications for your life like
you're gonna go look at every single
article obviously so it just doubled
down for me like how mary was all wrong
and then this week she was so wrong like
her
crusade against whitney for not
answering the four face times because
she was in the car and then i was like
oh but i guess she never called her back
when he said she called her back two
hours later
even if she didn't like you're busy you
forget it's not like she hates mary
they're good friends and especially
because as whitney said like she's been
mary's number one defender online on the
show like just always quelling these
like rumors about mary and just having
her back and it's like
awful the way that she treated her and
this stuff with the the mafia costume
yeah what the [ __ ] what was that
like trying to make like a joke for like
whitney into a joke right i just that
would have bothered me too rubbed me the
wrong i wouldn't have found it funny i i
might have not once i figured it out
like i might have not even gone like
it's so disrespectful like and
condescending because she didn't answer
your call what because you like you put
on your hat so you want you everyone
needed to pick up your
when you were when you were ready you're
wearing a hat yeah
literally it was so stupid she was being
so mean and condescending and it's not
like there was anything they were
actually fighting over so like
mary was saying these like really mean
condescending things and it's like there
was there was no fight there like it was
so stupid and you know and whitney's
like retort is like i love you so much
like what do you do you're my friend
what are you doing and mary is just
has no compassion no and then when they
start to get into whitney and meredith
talking about like you know what they're
as a being and how she believes that she
holds the power of god and so she wields
that power like i mean that's the you
know what it's giving david crash
yeah
it really is and like that's where i
think salt lake city stands apart
because that conversation wouldn't
happen anywhere else like we need to
talk to our friend mary because she's
wielding the power of god
in too harsh a way
literally
literally it's so bizarre and then they
all go back to the table like
everything's normal like it's it's
[ __ ] up yeah
it's like
this is our friend lisa like she's a
little condescending this is mary she
hosts the spirit of god she feels the
power of god you'll get used to her
but you know what mayor and like mary's
just like on this crusade like she did
invite jenny um but you know what like
i'm kind of over jenny she's like giving
me nothing
jenny gives me everything in the form of
her children when they came into the
kitchen you want to make yogurt of
course oh my god
i wanted to cry when they were like do
you want to make your of course mom i
would love to literally
and then the daughter comes in and she's
making yogurt
and then they were like there wasn't
enough they couldn't help enough like
claudia i'm in love with her children
yeah their kids are curious behave
campers i've ever seen on television
yeah and they were just
oh my gosh it warmed my heart every if
we don't get signed saturdays once an
episode i'm [ __ ] out that's true but
jenny in the group gives me nothing
right that's fine it's crazy i've never
felt this way about a housewife a
first-time housewife it's like you're
nesting where it's like i love her
personal scenes yeah just because those
kids the kids are special like they're
really they're really special yeah i
agree they are the sweetest and it like
her daughter is um
probably like under 10 so you know kids
are usually nice but like her son is is
like a young creature and he still is so
respectful and so excited to do science
and make yogurt like i just could cry no
literally
um okay so that was like a hot mess the
dad wants more kids they have of course
but also he should just be satisfied
with these gems that they have he's out
of control but they have the most
amazing kids why not make some more
literally
so the event was chaotic and you know
what mary was giving me like major
secondhand embarrassment like when she
was like trying to do an italian accent
but she didn't know how to say one word
in italian if i i mean maybe it just
like doesn't come off well on tv it
doesn't but these events look like
torture these ones that she throws oh
the one that mary's yeah because mary is
just like i think people just walk on
eggshells around her like they don't
know what to say you know like the
even last year the met gala one where
like they had to put on couture at noon
o'clock
and like just go to some strip mall yeah
to have a fine dining experience like
it's just like i would be like oh you
don't want to invite me that's fine yeah
that's fine even so this week
and what did you think about the aprons
in the louis vuitton bag okay it was
misleading it was misleading of course
heather thinks she went home with like a
louis vuitton apron and a hat and it's
literally america it's literally from
bed bath and beyond erica what the [ __ ]
was that i don't know
heather translates to eric and also
because last year she did give them
louis vuitton so right and it was in all
in the same louis vuitton
shopping bag like and then mary acting
like i'm not buying these girls
louboutin but you did but you bought
them headphones right
no it was she was lighting up so mean
she was gaslighting us it was so
it was crazy yeah and then when heather
was like i didn't even know louis
vuitton made aprons she said nothing
yeah
and then like slams them in her
interview yeah and she comes for the
other women's style so hard as if they
have the worst style and i think that
they all have pretty good style the only
one who's like a little
iffy if he's whitney probably um but
she's you know her own individual no
meredith is amazing style lisa has
really cute unique style heather always
looks like put together and she is 50
50. and jen has good jen dresses kind of
similar to mary and it's like mary
doesn't have objectively amazing style
like she's so hard on these girls like
like that they need to come like looking
like italian streetwear fabulous yeah
and by the way i hate when people make
like themed events with like the most
obscure theme italian streetwear like
what is that that's not she was saying
it's not like italian fashion it's like
it's really like
like low-key black i thought that
meredith nailed i agree
i thought mary wasn't italian streetwear
whatsoever
and like some of the women at least
tried to have like italian brands that
they were wearing or like jen shaw with
her italian flag
yeah but i think mary was wearing chanel
you know the whole thing made no [ __ ]
sense yeah but the pasta looked good
the pasta looked amazing and the burrata
like it looked like i was really hungry
while eating it yeah but like
i'm sorry just getting all the women
together to like cook
and beat an egg and make like penis
jokes is just a level of housewives that
i've graduated from especially when
we're waiting for this like pivotal
moment and they made it a 90-minute
episode when we really didn't need to
see that much of the cooking class yeah
and by the way i just want to say
justice for whitney because i i loved
her outfit to the she looked great she
looks right and she nailed both mafia
and
streetwear just in case 100
so i was a big fan so then let's get the
second that they pulled up a beauty lab
and laser like i froze i was like ben
you have to watch us and he was like why
i'm like just watch
so i was just like he didn't know what
was gonna happen he knows nothing and so
when she was like i'm like her husband
has internal breathing he's like oh my
that's terrible like just wait by the
way when she was saying sharif senior i
was like is that sharif's dad i assumed
it was sharif's dad no but she needed a
really good excuse to get out of there
in five minutes and she has a son sharif
junior right so at first i was like okay
sharif senior that's pretty good and
also it's a little bit like removed it's
not like a crazy thing to say but to say
that about your husband
it's just like a wild thing to put out
there no it's like what we call a kanai
nahara like yeah it's like a
superstition like never say yeah so she
she was desperate like when she got that
first phone call it was funny she was
taking these phone calls and she wasn't
saying one word she was like so prepared
it was because i'm sure the person on
the other line whoever it was knows that
she's filming yeah you know knows the
fbi is here and they're coming for you
like
it was sure for sure right
i don't know
did they go to her house first but
doesn't she eventually did she got
arrested at her house or does she turn
herself in
she turned herself in i believe
so maybe it was sharif and they went to
the house first that's what i thought
because otherwise how would they know
how would anyone know that they're
coming for her right
so so whoever called her was like
if you're filming don't say anything
want to let you know fbi is on their way
get out of it so they made it like a
weird thing like moment that meredith
decided to meet them in veil and there's
like a lot of talk this season about
whether meredith tipped off the fbi that
they were at beauty lab and laser but
also married and go mary like had a
headache she was still laying in bed
yeah so there's proof that it was either
one of them even though i don't think it
was hard to find out where gen challenge
was what if they tip them off like they
could have been there to see in the
first of their life right right but like
as the day went honestly if i was the
one who tipped off i would want to see
it go down to see like everyone
it dawned on everyone no obviously and
like the more the the more the day went
on people started dropping out i'm like
oh my they're gonna be so pissed that
they missed this like it really happened
so perfectly like if it was like this
stage thing all the women would have
been there like i
no part of me thinks anything was staged
no it was so iconic so like they're all
sitting and honestly the fact that
heather was the only one who got up and
talked to the police like i would have
been so [ __ ] curious but they were
all just like frozen like looking out
the window i'm like get up like get in
there yeah but they still don't know
that they're looking for jen right lisa
said on watch what happens live that she
thought that they were looking for
heather because they're at beauty lab
right you know so they don't that's why
like we we know what they're doing there
but like them they're slowly piecing
together like
these okay the cops are in this
parking lot they're here for us
they're looking for jen and it's
homeland security like these are federal
i'm so glad heather asked what's h
s i s i he's like homeland security i
was like oh my gosh this is federal
federal
it was
just all her luggage in the no she
didn't she put in the pickup truck her
big luggages yeah they didn't see them
heather said she took her bags and left
she took her bags from the van i know
everybody's just still in the car
because it was she was like the third
person there they would have had i i
think she was like had no time she's not
going to get stuck there so do they
still go to vail
yes so andy said how much happens live
that next week's episode he said his top
five episodes he said that last week
about next week that it's top five
episodes
of housewives ever it's about six it's
over the course of about eight hours and
it's their ride to veil
learning everything yeah i mean
whitney's the one who figures it out
like on twitter or something and like
lisa is calling her lawyers to see
what's on the docket and they're piecing
together in the car that's crazy jenny
just like stumbled into this
it's crazy i'm glad they're still going
to vail me too but because how far is it
i don't know colorado and utah right
yeah yeah
i don't know
it's just like why not fly i'm glad they
didn't otherwise this wouldn't have been
so iconic orchestrated moment that it
was no like the everything that happened
like it just happened perfectly like i
cannot believe that they were filming
like and whoever did not put their
camera down like if you saw a swat t
no matter how much you want to get shot
you put your [ __ ] camera down like
you're scared yeah whoever deserves a
pulitzer like he did not even waver once
the camera didn't shake it was gorgeous
and all the gopros that they had on the
bus were amazing too yeah
and them thinking it was a prank like is
something like those women would do
whitney thought it was strippers yeah
it's hysterical yeah but it also just
goes to show like how
naive they were and like you know
they're processing that sharif has
internal bleeding right right and so i
think he's like i realized
yeah that's not true and your friend is
a fraud yeah
so it was insane
it really gripped me yeah it was
ben was shook
he was like what like she was running
one of the largest telemarketing schemes
in the country yeah
it was it was very well done they did
make us wait like a long ass time to get
to that part and you know what's
frustrating it's like at this point in
the season up until that van i was like
i have a team jen i had turned a corner
on jennifer squad yeah she had turned a
corner like and i thought the way that
she
um handled herself at the lunch like
even though like mary like she was just
even i just have been feeling her but
that conversation she had while snow
shoeing with stew yeah was like
like creepy like like they knew like
they were just talking about how they've
like been so great for each other you
know like it was like have this like
conclusive vibe to the conversation yeah
i mean i'm sure we'll find out
you know if she what she
where she was at like did she know she
was under investigation right all these
things was she maybe like closing up
shop a little bit because like things
got too crazy for her even her
i don't know
i'm just
in
it was [ __ ] crazy it was crazy you're
shocked i'm shocked
um so yes i'm very jazzed for next
week's episode andy has said multiple
times like it is one of the best
episodes of housewives he's ever seen i
can imagine i think these women are just
great like i love the salt lake city
women i think they're
just amazing yeah no i agree um
and look like
the outlook for the season yeah is
bright it's looking up it's looking up
yeah um and that is our show right yep
that is our show i don't think it was
anyone else's but i could be wrong such
a good point oh my god in daylight
savings like the lighting is now [ __ ]
up and now we're like really the sun
comes in at a different time now how
nice we get some sun no no but it's like
oh my god you're so bright yeah i'm
washed out okay oh good i'm still like
dark and ugly don't worry about me
that's a wrap then thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cats blocks all the places where
we listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are
and if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations you are true
toaster who listens to the end of the
episode because you value what we have
to say and you never know what we're
going to say at the end of the show if
you made it to the end in honor of
gensha being arrested put the little
police siren on our most recent
instagram post
bye guys bye